se3 not event that for premieres on
National Geographic Memorial Day night
and then it's six episodes about the
origins of Ebola and how it jumped all
the way across the United States soil
soil in 1989 saw a couple episodes of it
already and it's proof that this man to
my right just doesn't act in anything
for the faint of heart I'll be very
honest with you the hot zone is gonna
come on National Geographic again later
this month and he is also sir Davos from
Game of Thrones good to see you liam
Cunningham delight to be here so thanks
for helping ya know romantic comedies of
late from you right yeah I think it
might have been a bit old for the
romantic grandfather comedies maybe is
there such a thing I'm not gonna limit
you you're not gonna learn you have
range thank you you have you have range
you don't do agent work that you
couldn't be my age we have again I know
it's your first go-round here on this
show this show provides a bump for
people what we leave we leave actors
actresses musicians in general in a
better place than we found them that's
good if some of us are in a terrible
position to start over well you're in a
good spot right now yeah Monday like
life is good for you yeah it's
remarkably good for the moment too sir
but the the actor's life is up-and-down
so what we're offering is there's a
surfing one I'm serving a wave the beach
is not far off okay enjoy the wave where
they were on it is there much surfing in
Ireland the World Championships have
been in Ireland okay so a massive
Ireland's yeah the claim that we steal
all their all their surf because our
little island is in the way right
and so you are born and raised just
outside of Dublin correct yeah Dublin
born and brandy okay now what is the
living there alright used to live there
okay what is your before you get into
your work your sports likes or at all
like what sport do you focus in on or
Formula one I love absolutely love
Formula one why is that well it's kind
of the pinnacle I mean a lot of people
will look at motor racing and they
obviously think of NASCAR and IndyCar
and Indy 500 right but but firmly one is
is slightly different and if you take
into consideration that the people
leading the
the championship at the moment Mercedes
have between 13 and 15 hundred people
working to get two cars round and their
budgets yeah are like six seven eight
hundred million a year right
it's it's the pinnacle it's it's
whatever its new whatever is the tech
most technologically advanced yet goes
on these cars so they're they're they're
really avant-garde and you like just
edgy and and then you get all the
politics in the background and all that
sort of stuff I love it so he's your
favorite driver at the moment yeah it's
very difficult to get away from Lewis
Hamilton he's remarkable on this season
I've never seen him every sentence out
of his mouth it's just maturity and and
indecent he's he's he's already showing
signs that he may run away with this
championship but I think even though
he's one point behind the leader right I
still think there's something there's
something in this is swagger is just
saying he's the man so I mean how does
it a driver have swagger if you don't
mind me asking do you think having the
best car helps work of our to occur so
who's your favorite driver of all time
Matt would you say I was very lucky I'm
Michael Schumacher in flat and I take a
lot of photographs I was on the grid in
Monaco and I don't think if I may have
not shown anybody this and I take a lot
of photographs okay I'm Michael
shoemakers last Monaco I was on the grid
and I leaned down right beside his car
and I got my father and I have a
close-up I had the last close-up shot
with Michael in the car in his last
Monaco before he retired and then got
injured him in for people who don't know
he was a huge war five-time world
champion 720 or Tourmaline oh I know I
know and he is arguably the greatest
Formula One driver that ever got into a
current I got to tell you I've never
been a liam Cunningham again of the hot
zone on National Geographic and also sir
Davos from Game of Thrones here in the
Rich Eisen show I've never been to an f1
race and I bet it is
and I would love to like if I to choose
any place on the planet would have to be
more
right it's known as the jewel in the
crown of I would just think it would be
just like being in a James Bond movie
it's exactly what it is there's people
with too much money and no taste some of
them someone I have friends that live
there right but you do know what Jack
Nicholson referred to Monaco as Oh
Alcatraz for the rich he does a
wonderful em English writer called
Somerset monde referred the money was as
a sunny place for shady people but but I
think they were probably just jealous
that they were in to live right go there
I mean I love these put beautiful it
sucks I don't even know how to play back
around I'd probably lose all my money in
ten minutes right I just don't even know
how the hell did it just go in there and
just hang out go to an f1 race yeah you
drink champagne right and of course it's
the law stuff you have your Monaco card
revoked if you don't drink that very
very easily you don't want to be trying
okay so then it is the way I would
imagine it is it's very close to what to
what you're saying yeah yeah and they do
so the other thing they say before me
the one and specifically because so many
of them live in that area yeah is
there's an old question of how do you
make a small fortune of a Formula One
start with a large one that's right
exactly that's what they say about the
wine business - yeah how do you make a
small fortune in the wine business know
where the large one liam Cunningham here
on the Rich Eisen show okay before I get
out with you on game of thrones like
probably ever the human being on the
planet
let's talk about the hot zone on
National Geographic what a cast Topher
Grace julianna margulies
just to name two and you know ahem Erick
as well wonderful people yeah absolutely
so what's this about for I don't know we
just discussed it but I'll give you the
floor and what it's about and why people
should go watch it well their stories is
based very much on a true events I
haven't in 1989 so what's that thirty
years ago yeah and we're a bola was
unleashed ten miles from the White House
the lucky thing was as various strains
of this particular horrific disease I
think most most most people know how bad
this thing is and what as I was saying
what's what
incredibly important is that not this is
not just a piece that you know a
historical piece of news that were
dramatizing the second largest outbreak
of a ball is happening as we speak in
the Congo so it's incredibly important
that in a sense we get this message out
I mean a scientific community is aware
of it but we are not pushing hard enough
what happens is this is only a plane
ride away from it coming back here or my
country or anybody else's or Australia
or anywhere else in Africa hmm so it's
incredibly important that we get this
out however we're not trying to preach
the people were we're trying to sell
this remarkable drama with with the
Magnificent julianna margulies and Noah
and Topher and everybody else so we want
to get this story up in as entertaining
a fashion as possible but at the same
time we run not to you and we all know
how they're connected to the scientific
community as natural world it's the
perfect place to get it out there so
what is the message that you want to get
out there or the makers again it's based
on the book by Richard Preston the hot
zone what what is the message we need to
throw the kitchen sink everything at
this at this problem is achievable look
at smallpox in the past and polio right
we've virtually eradicated those this
can be done here the first 15 minutes of
our show shows in yeah terrific details
what I mean for not the faint of heart
yes what what this can do to it to a
human being and and we're not doing her
job properly if we don't try and contain
this particular beast of a virus and
that's again a six-episode series it's
to and i essentially starting on
Memorial Day night on National
Geographic at 8:00 9:00 Eastern Time so
make note of that right right here right
now okay how'd you get a call to be sir
table yeah let me talk about this with
him it's it's kind of it's kind of weird
and well another producer saw me in
something that they really liked and
they brought me up for a particular role
right at the outset I didn't come in
until the beginning of the second season
right they saw me for another role and
then what are the role was I'm not
telling you that wouldn't be fair on the
other actor I'll keep that for my
memoirs all right was it John Snow just
come on
process of elimination they brought me
back I thought it was getting the usual
Hollywood heave-ho when they said look
there's more this time Italian next time
yeah sure whatever
and through enough the guys came back
and said look we have this thing that we
think is a great fit for you and I went
up and it was said that was Seaworth and
I've been there for seven of the eight
seasons yeah and it's it's it's been
amazing amazing time so the time by the
time you you got the role of sir Davos
we had already known Game of Thrones was
a well we are well know nobody anybody
says they knew that it was gonna be huge
as a filthy liar
we we we knew it was gonna be good right
I'd read the scripts and I I've been
long enough doing this to know something
beautiful when I say right and when I'd
seen the first 10 episodes I just went
oh my god I can't believe I'm gonna be
part of this story right because it was
approached for us and they mentioned my
agent mentioned dragons and shadow
babies and I went let me stop you there
love and she went oh no look this is
this is HBO soprano people but blah blah
blah and I said all right let me see the
script yeah and I just went this is just
astonishingly beautiful right and that's
all an actor can help for and the
character sir Davos I mean what your
character liam Cunningham has seen do
you know do you know how it and I know
everything you do know everything I am
the article like Brahms no seriously
though as you and I are sitting here
right now you liam Cunningham me rich
eyes yeah you do know how everything
ends in a couple of weeks yes I do
okay sometimes their alternate ending
shot at Tibet or alternate scripts that
have been put in front of the actors and
actresses yes they've done it to me
they've done it to a couple of couple of
characters on the show but they're just
for cakes
they've sent yeah so you know how this
thing ends right yeah
you've only the way two weeks my week
and a half my Thursday did you know what
that's true like every single time where
you're the fourth member of the cast
there's been here we've had kid
Harrington Lena Headey and John
ah Fifi nobody ever gives anything up
and I feel like I go down the same road
every single day and and then look at me
love it with overtrained and Langley
that's why that's it
well they all look at me like why do you
even want to know like don't you want to
know it's very strange
listen we get it all the time I'll be
obviously anybody that comes across and
there's a huge interest and it's really
gratifying because it it sort of reminds
us that we're trying the best and we're
doing as good as we can of people really
appreciate it however when you're
bumming into a stranger it's there for
one opportunity to say please to tell me
something yes they have to ask I'm gonna
feel it really naughty I'll go oh okay
I'll tell you they go no don't but I
don't want to know that's the fact of it
that's true by the way that's a great
way to put it sir Davos way of putting
it right there yeah he's yourself I'm
buried in character I'm into the sir
Davos voice right you dipped right in
what is again liam Cunningham here in
the Rich Eisen show what is the
strangest theory that a fan has come up
to you and said I think this is what
Game of Thrones is about or whatever
like well listen I get them all the time
I got this I smiled politely and then I
call psychiatric services and someone
I've had some really weird I've been
accused of being a Zora ah hi which is
this guy who has never shown up the Lord
of Light the boss the main man I there's
a but what I treat those kind of things
as as an incredible compliment because
we've been doing it so long it's
incredibly difficult to predict and
people are still going is it this is it
that it means it means we're achieving
what we set out to achieve which is to
entertain and and have people kind of
going mad we're gonna work it out
what's your who's your favorite
character my favorite character on the
show outside of you um
well Terry a materialist fantastic you
know I drink and I know things I try to
live my life like that that's right and
I usually drink and then forget
everything I loved his dad ty when
Charles dance I'm a big fan of his time
yes who got heard on the on the
I'll seat on the potty yeah that's not
great or whatever um so just at least
this give me this luckily lean
Cunningham the next episode yes one this
Sunday when they open up and I love the
open where you just zoom in from
different places yeah when they zoom in
on Winterfell yeah on the open on the
credits do we see a Starbucks yes
because I haven't seen the Starbucks
that was the Winterfell branch of
Starbucks actually that she got that
from yeah we usually keep out of the
frame yes there has been a there's been
a Starbucks franchise there for quite a
number seen that lourd Fanti of
Winterfell there it is right there yeah
there it is right there did you did you
not know but nobody caught that busy
acting looking for coffee cups when
we're supposed to be portraying thank
God got out of this alive the Battle of
Winterfell all right last one for you
here where are you planning on watching
the finale Liam I have given up this is
her big geeks we are in her house okay
six of us in the house the family unlike
the daughters fiance and we sit on the
couch watching them I'm seeing them the
same time as you guys not only that I
think it up a much of a 2 a.m. because
of the symulast and the time difference
so I've given up my can Film Festival
this year to sit at home on a couch with
my family to watch the last ever episode
of Game of Thrones to be with your
family yes walk me through who's there
who's in my three children my daughter
my two sons my wife my my daughter's
fiance okay and we'll be all there
watchin and how how old are your
children
yeah my girls 26 and two boys 22 and 18
okay that'd have been great if you like
my because that's what I keep thinking
that the kids acting in this and my lord
you know I mean it's gotta leave them a
little scarred so that's how you're
gonna watch the finale yeah yeah I'm
gonna do that you know but the rest of
your family does not know they have a
death pool beside the TV come on now I'm
not even kidding you that and their
whole family are there and when they're
putting up what do you think what do you
think they're doing this they're looking
to save
anything in my eyes that might help them
okay now I'd like the torch of them
alright well we have we have our own
survivor pool here if if you wouldn't
mind just because we're going to take a
break just one more television only
segment I'd like to run through them
with you
let's do and you could tell me if I'm
not gonna tell you anything that's my
chin gently look we'll walk through all
of that but again the hot zone I mean
this is some awesome television it's it
couldn't be more timely or important
yeah absolutely it's a thriller this is
not just scientific information we're
getting across it's an incredibly
interesting story that hops between
Africa and and Washington yeah so it's
the may is the month of liam Cunningham
a couple of weeks it's the finale of
Game of Thrones and then starting on
Memorial Day night a three night event
two episodes per night six-episode
series based on the book by Richard
Preston the hot zone 9:00 Eastern Time
on National Geographic at I am
Cunningham one on both Twitter and
Instagram good to see you sir
big fan of your work a pleasure having
you here thanks very much problem you
guys that's liam Cunningham here on the
Rich Eisen show we'll wrap this show up
in a moment a couple more minutes left
with liam Cunningham I put up on the
screen right here he says he's not gonna
give it away but these are these are our
picks these are right now that's my
survivor pool right now bran tyrion arya
like that's it but it's just we just had
300 your 11:3 yeah we tried you think
we'll make it to the end - correct
okay Jon Snow Sam Tarly Sansa Stark as
Chris Brockman's three right yeah well
his first round selection the night king
CEO he's already here okay what do you
think so his idea was those three would
survive right one of them was already
he's totally unreliable already isn't he
I think so yeah we need to just push him
so light and somebody looking for blink
once if you like one if you like my
anything can happen all right we've had
Kelsey Grammer and Dennis Haysbert and
other guests of ours with some great
cards would you mind reading these on
come on there either of those ten legs
the best sir dabo's to read into that
microphone you
watching the Rich Eisen show the testing
was that a bit serial killer that's good
okay welcome back to the rich handsome
show ladies and gentlemen liam
Cunningham everybody Kelsey Grammer I
wouldn't even get into a competition up
mom's voices honey you're bad again the
hot zone on national geographic a
three-night six show events starting on
Memorial Day night with this man watch
it for more of the Rich Eisen show tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on VR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app